all right Cuddy looks like the shoe is
on the other hatless time today's get
ready to die
mega bottle run hi you calling me a
six-year-old girl I'm out of arrows
impossible wait a minute we're justice
for dramatic effect up fake out with
only one arrow in my eyes be a unicorn
oh this isn't what I really had in mind
ah you got me there good job rope swing
pro ethics on it because I am Oh No
[Music]
99% impossible ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
kill your boss you're fired give me the
baby
Oh try this again hang on rainbow ball
throw I think I remember playing
something like this before like this
before like this before I'm faking you
guys out okay well I'm gonna go throw it
oh my throw it I'm actually gonna throw
it why can't I grab on to you why can't
I grab oh yeah we go oh ha just go fall
fall like gentle butterfly doing good
doing good doing good roll on a roll run
hard thanks for taking all the arrows
for me kid
ah pants I'm dead ow oh yeah all right
kitties we're in another jet fall here
so look you're good that's right we're
big and fat will you catch can handle
that you could handle me
you can handle that's good
ah-ha-ha-ha double throat Oh help me I'm
okay I'm okay trash can
let's get a little okay huh go right
down the side right down the side there
right down the side oh wow
we're okay we're okay we're okay right
down Oh Oh dad glitch why unconscionable
dual toilet race white my toilet no
catch a ball
[Applause]
dual toilet race you got told me to grab
onto some before done okay go man go
whoops look like wind so black so end
right oh so close
hi you know someone actually told me in
one of the comments in the other videos
did the secret to the bottle run is to
hold up and tap left and I'm like have
you seen my other videos we need to
angular eyes this a little bit to the
right there man no no not left right to
the right go right dammit dammit dammit
not the trash can again get in there no
dad my till alive I'm not anymore all
right it's not my case where are you oh
my god
[Applause]
[Music]
kill the toilet king no how do I kill
the toilet King if I'm going Star Wars
sore throat kid Anakin you deserve death
well all's gotta hit him anyway cuz I no
no I'm Anakin I'm an old Anakin
apparently high fat mace windu I'm gonna
get you come on flip flip something now
I'm coming for your toilet King baby
aren't you dead one more try we're no
mas okey-dokey here we go double flip
okay what this isn't killing the toilet
King that's something else entirely you
miss me ah smash
[ __ ] get out of here yeah BMX and
escape he stopped having such a negative
attitude about things kidney and we owe
sick tricks breath yeah ah kill my kid
but that's okay goalkeeper Oh
yo don't think you can get Benny balls
that I 99.9% impossible I better analyze
it situation of it seems to be a big
swing ball a lot of Mines well time to
go kid you didn't really help me out
there
push push I push you all right down
BMX again trying twice twice as nice
whoosh oh yeah
sick tricks bro it didn't kill my kid oh
no no no no oh my god enjoy I'm a ninja
and I will attack I missed I missed
again
[ __ ] what island or there we go does
sake cocky cocky da gookie all right
kids I gotta put the button we were my
cage actually be on a rope swing I am
too um a muscular to be in a rope swing
I'm so massive it's my muscles downhill
madness no Joe Joe you're so crazy
yeah go man go oh oh that's probably not
good what God my hide oh you couldn't do
not know
very well how do I throw to
independently no good take that helmet
say my where'd I go am i coming back
down where will I land God just didn't
help at all element ha
John my son's arm oh my first
[Music]
[Laughter]
have to be the greatest does box
this has been happy wheels highlights
thanks for watching if you like what
your son you want to see more why not
subscribe to my channel want to help the
channel grow
leave a like add it to your favorites or
share it with your friends on Facebook
and Twitter thanks again and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]